in Northwestern France the Avon tour
sailing ship is an impressive site the
boat is more than a century old but very
much turned towards the future it uses
only wind power to carry cargo on
Journeys that are largely free of carbon
emissions and pollution
we started this because we saw the need
for clean transport clean sea transport
and then we also want to draw the
attention to our consumerism the way we
consume Goods the way we consume Goods
requires large amounts of of ships that
carry well in my eyes useless stuff and
that creates a lot of pollution for the
Earth which is absolutely unnecessary so
we want to offer an alternative global
Shipping accounts for three percent of
the world's annual carbon emissions the
industry has set a target of halving
them by 2050.
says wind power could be part of the
solution he works for a French company
that's building one of the world's
biggest cargo sailing ships
lots of ideas have been considered by
the big shipping companies like
attaching a big sale to container ships
or using LNG but none of them have come
up with something workable like the
sailing ship that we are building demand
for wind powered transportation is
growing an increasing number of
companies are signing up to have their
goods carried by sailing ships because
it is good for the planet but is also
good for business
in eastern France the country's only
carbon neutral champagne producer uses
electric machinery and sustainable
methods and we use 80 of recycled glass
which uses less energy to melt Michelle
trappier transformed his generation's
old estate because he's passionate about
the environment he'll soon use sailboats
to ship his champagne to clients abroad
it's more expensive to carry the wine
that way but I'm sure that some
consumers a majority of consumers in the
future will do appreciate the fact that
the transportation doesn't produce any
any carbon sailing boats are unlikely to
replace container ships soon as they're
slower and can't carry as much but as
Energy prices soar and concern over
climate change grows they could help the
shipping industry to change tack Natasha
Butler Al Jazeera duanane Northwestern
France